unto you today
we have our special friend sheikh saeed
raga
who is here with us on the dean show and
we're going to be talking about
good manners good etiquettes because you
know what it's easy to be a thug
you want to be a gangster you want to be
a thug you want to curse
you want to act out a line that's easy
but how do you get in line
it takes some discipline that takes a
little bit of work so we're going to get
some advice from the sheikh when we come
back here on the d show don't go nowhere
this is the thing you know
this is the angels
you're still playing ball absolutely
have you ever gotten dunked down
now be real you got in islam you gotta
tell the truth
has anyone ever coming over and just
dunked on you
well probably happened once or twice
once or twice once or twice
so this is this i'm willing to take the
charge you know i'm willing to go there
okay this this is not you're not an nba
superstar but
you are someone who is really
influential amongst the youth
you play ball you keep it real the real
deal
but you're not a thug nor a gangster
you're a muslim one who has submitted
to the will of the one god why is it
easy to be a thug
but it's harder to be disciplined and be
righteous talk to a sheik
well it's all misunderstanding i mean
these young people they
listen to this music they watch these
movies so they think you know
to be cool you got to be a thought
you got to be out of line you got to be
using a certain language you got to walk
a certain way
but what they don't understand is
walking on the wild side
we're outside exactly it's not like this
now when you pray in public now you're
walking on the wild side when you pray
in public by the way of all the prophets
absolutely
when you stop shooting the ball and you
say hey time for salah
now you are walking on the wild side and
you know what's so funny
because we did this you know you you
almost you know winning or losing the
game and it's just a friendly game
and everybody's tense everybody wants
excited ones they want to win or they
want you know
and then you say no time for maghrib how
many persons what are you doing
i said allahu akbar and he stopped
dribbling the ball
out of respect now when they see you
doing this
they say no i'm taking my hat off for
you you know you're a man of principles
you don't have to curse you don't have
to lie you don't have to you know
use certain words to impress them just
being a muslim
behaving like the prophets doing what is
necessary that would impress these guys
i'm telling you so why do you think many
people they resort
to the easy way because this way does it
take some influence because
when you get angry it's easy to let some
foul dirty language out of your mouth
but is this acceptable in islam is it
acceptable for
the same tongue that you use to praise
the creator can foul language come out
of this mouth
any weak person can do this
any an intelligent in the individual
can't say these things you're going to
let his anger go her anger go you know
but
only elite only the elite only small
number of people can suppress that anger
you know and the behavior in a certain
pa in a certain certain manner
and then deal with the people like that
so
i don't think it's necessary for you to
use language or to be
like that but just be yourself now
taking role models
as those who are always using profanity
50 cents
tupac britney spears all these other pop
stars you got their pictures up in the
room
and they're probably using the worst of
language acting the worst the way so
isn't it natural
if you're taking these as role models
then you're going to probably emulate
them
and you're going to start to succumb to
what they felt
and they're doing and that's fine i mean
if these people are heading
they booking the tickets to johannam
that's fine i mean but if they want to
go to jannah and be with the righteous
be with allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
be with the prophets this is not the way
to go this is
absolutely the wrong direction they
should not be
taking these individuals as role models
they should look into
what most objects they should look into
what abdullah ibn maser did
when abba jahan came and he grabbed him
by the ear and picked him by the air and
abdullah ibn masrid
landed with his on his feet with one ear
only
you know how did he respond what did he
do
this is the people we should take them
as a role model not like these people
now tell us you mentioned jannah is this
something
that's the you know people get hooked up
on hollywood bollywood
and they start to fantasize and now
their heart
and their mind and their bodies yearning
towards this but you said janna
talk to us a little bit about jenna's
get people excited for janna
three things see the first thing is
that allah called you he's a slave his
servant
and that itself is a title that you
should be proud of
not the being proud of you being
belonging to this group or that group
but simply by saying i am one of the
servants of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and that's why the poet he said um
what made me so proud so happy that you
are allah subhanahu wa
call me my slave you call me and i am
your slave
so the messenger of allah said allah
said i have prepared for my servant
which no eyes have ever seen
no one ever heard of and now all the
description of jannah that we have in
the quran in the sunnah
in comparison on the reality of jannah
it's nothing
you cannot even imagine your mind cannot
comprehend the beauty and what we have
in jannah
and then allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala said
and this is for the righteous
now in jannah is everything that we
dream of everything that we like
everything that we want and i think we
should aim for that rather than aiming
for these
worldly little things that will vanish
tomorrow it's going to be gone right
absolutely we're going to leave it all
behind no matter how much wealth you
accumulate
it's gone at the end what matters what
goes down to your grave with you what's
going to follow down there
your ammo your action your actions your
deeds
good deeds absolutely and you mentioned
now for the not yet muslims those who
are out there
they're sincere they want to know the
truth and we say some arabic words so
for them we like to define because
there's a lot of misconceptions you said
allah subhanahu wa
what does this mean allah you know the
one who deserves all the praises
and thanks so when we say alhamdulillah
we say all praises do to allah
so this is the words that we use because
we
respect allah we hold him in high esteem
so
every time we mention his name we say
alhamdulillah or subhanallah say all
praises due to allah we glorify him
so this is not a moon god no something
in the creation this is the one true
creator no no a little house in the
middle of that doesn't
no no no so this is the one true creator
one true
creator that we all worship we don't
worship anyone else this is the same god
jesus peace be upon him
absolutely let's take a break you heard
that here on the dean she'll be right
back
you have to pray as if everything
depends on allah and it does
but you must work as if everything
depends on you
and it doesn't that's my point
you see what i'm saying and i don't like
that i don't like us sitting here what
are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
are you waiting for all these people to
come to islam what are we waiting for
what are we waiting for right now when
they're going to come they're going to
come along and bring these people
lost upon the water put in our hand the
ability to do it now do your job
i am not afraid to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
is by myself
i am not afraid to stand alone
and we're talking about good manners
it's easy to be a thug
it's easy to be a gangster all you got
to do is throw on some of the
movies that they out here and you know
what you get influence
you throw on tony soprano scarface
goodfellas and now you're talking
different you're acting different
and you're being a clown but that only
leads
away from jannah doesn't it absolutely
it'd be only
fair because the quran the verbatim word
of god it calls the people to worship
the creator not his creation over and
over it talks about the good
and glad tidings of paradise but if a
person is insistent
rebellious criminal what is the
antithesis the opposite of what's
waiting for that person
you know i really don't want to go there
it's scary you know it's very
scary and very difficult place to go
very
um i i can't even
imagine myself being there wow may allah
may allah prevent and allah protect
us from going there i mean but there is
no comfort there
no comfort there's no happiness it's
only tears and screams and cries
and i don't want to be part of that
party i don't
and you know what's so unique
stated in the quran on the day of
judgment
that this unique speaker will come and
would address the crowd
and this is shaytan and he would take
the podium and he will say to the people
in the law indeed allah promised you the
true promise
and i promise you the false promise but
you disobey your creator and you obeyed
me
today do not blame me blame yourselves
the devil this is
the chief deceiver he's going to be
saying that is the final
speech nobody's going to speak after
that
and this is a place this is a one
lecture i don't want to listen to
i don't know this is one place that i
don't want to be
and this is one gathering that i don't
want to be part of
i mean naturally if you compare islam
which is simply the call to acquire
peace by submitting
your entire will yourself to the owner
of peace the creator of the heavens and
earth and a muslim is one who does the
action
so now if you look at what shaped down
the devil is calling you to pornography
swearing cursing gambling alcohol drugs
and all these things that they don't
bring peace and contentment serenity to
heart
do they no they don't and what is so
unique is when as soon as you're done
with one thing you're another thing
you know and this is what the messenger
of allah said
he said jannah you know he allah created
jannah and jahannam hell and and heavens
and then he said to jibril go and take a
look at them
and then he went to heaven and he says
oh allah
no one ever hear of this except that he
or she wants to be part of it once
enter paradise and then allah said go
back i added something to it
and then he went and allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala put
all the difficulties and hardship and
you know a little struggle there around
heaven and then jabil came back he said
only the chosen ones would make it
because when you go through difficulties
and you say only today let me pass this
let me pass this test
and then you take one more step forward
and then you keep taking steps forward
until you fall into jannah
on the counter in jahannam hell fire
allah subhana wa te ana or the put a lot
of desires around it
pornography girls you know movies
you know drinking and all this and he
said just let me enjoy one more time
let me just smoke this one more time let
me just have fun with her one more time
so one step towards johannam and before
you know it you're part of it
so that's why it's very scary and these
things that they do
you will never see any of these guys
saying that you know i'm enjoying myself
i'm enjoying this i don't want to get
out of it and that's why
all these new muslims all these people
except islam
you know napoleon you know all these
guys they could have stayed there
you know no one could stay there you
know this is what everyone wants to go
this is the direction that you know
everybody or every young man thinks this
is the ultimate happiness but they're
running away from it
david chappelle he's running away from
it because they know
there is no peace there there is no
happiness
and when you sit with these people who
experience and live that lifestyle
they will tell you listen we know what
it's all about don't go there don't go
we just came back from there and they
found peace
and happiness in islam not in you know
drugs and drinking and girls and
partying music none of that
and every time and anytime you grab one
of these people who
in that business and you ask him are you
happy
they will tell you i'm miserable people
seem to get confused like
good time fun from happiness it's
different
pleasure is temporary and then it has
side effects doesn't it absolutely so so
happiness is what we really want
contentment that's what we want
and this is what you can get in islam
peace of mind happiness you know you
come home
you know subhanallah some people think
brothers say
and don't you lose sleep over all these
things that's happening in media you
know
people not muslim or you know those are
trying to
you know harm muslims you know and i
said you know
no i don't worry about those things
because my heart is with allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
and as long as this is what i have i
don't care
you know the other night this is a funny
thing my wife said you know
you sleep before before your head hits
the pillow i say no
i don't she says you have no worries you
you're living this life but there's no
i said you know no i don't sleep that
quick and she said i'll time you you
know how long it took me
two minutes and 58 seconds she timed you
huh
now i said in the morning she said look
what you did to i said you know
there are a lot of people out there
would buy this with millions of dollars
a lot of people cannot sleep at night a
lot of people will take
you know take medication you know pills
just to and
alhamdulillah why because i said to
myself
allah is the one who controls heart and
it's my heart with allah
nothing matters if the house only fought
on the other side
i'll still sleep because allah allah
gave me the insurance
allah gave me the insurance that i will
be protected i don't have to worry about
it
so the youth now those who have went
astray
and they're around the bad company and
they're
living and emulating this life of
gangsters
and thugs but now somehow
a parent a friend they invited him now
to watch the dean show
and they're listening and you know the
heart the inside
it's yearning for something and but
they're caught in this group
it's not cool to be a good person but
you get praise for being
obnoxious for swearing how do we get
them practical tips to get them
away from evil and more towards
righteousness
number one listen to your heart
and examine your heart are you happy
is there a peace in your heart are you
feel that wow
you know i'm so comfortable in this life
i'm so happy
the answer is you know and we all we
both know that
second don't be full of what you see
because tomorrow they will walk away
from you
come back to allah and allah will be on
your side until you die
and even in your grave allah would be on
your side subhanallah
third you know as long in this circle
you will never
improve you will never change and you
will never better be a better person
so what i would encourage you to do is
break out of this circle
or this cycle and move forward and be
with allah
now did all the messages of god
including noah abraham jesus peace be
upon him and the last and final minister
of prophet
peace be upon him did they we talked
about the day of judgment paradise
hellfire
worshipping the one god not his creation
did they all call to this
way what we're calling to and this
righteousness developing yourself to be
the best
human being this is the message that
adam came with
then noah abraham you know moses jesus
muhammad
all of them one message and that is to
worship
one unique god one god one god
no one else no father no son no daughter
no wife no mother
no any statues no camels nor cows none
of that
one unique god do i have to put
something in front of me
and go through this statue or go through
let's say a dead person in the ground
absolutely pray through in the name of
jesus in the name of muhammad do i have
to do any of this absolutely what is so
beautiful
about this is you can go
and talk to your lord directly you don't
need a third party
you need someone to intercede for you
it's you
and your lord no one else and this is
the beauty of islam
that person who's watching now
everything makes sense but he's
right now i'm telling you late night
they're catching the dean so this person
right now
he's smoking a joint this is the real
world he's smoking a joint
but he's like i need to change
can he right now is there hope from if
he leaves it could he beseech god
and could he turn to god and ask god
what's the first step that he needs to
do
allah is so merciful and allah subhanahu
wa
it will welcome you any moment that you
come back to any moment
regardless of what you did if you killed
someone if you stole
if you lied if you use drugs if you
commit all
allah will forgive and forget all that
as a matter of fact every bad thing that
you did
allah will transfer that evilly into
good deed
and when you come to islam or when you
repent everything that you did
will be transferred into a good account
and you have hasana
to work with you have good deeds to work
with so i would say
get up you know start near fresh life
and move forward to allah
great advice we'll be right back for
more here on the dean show there will
always
be someone that will be there to say
something negative but at the same time
there'll be someone there to say
something positive also
just hold on to the rope of allah
everything in this universe
the quran says don't kill women don't
kill children don't kill the old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the prophet muhammad told us
that the prophet saws never ever start a
war against anyone am not afraid to
stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
is by messiah i am not afraid to stand
alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if a lie
is by messiah i am not afraid to stand
alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
is
back here on the dean show and we're
trying to encourage and invite to
goodness
and repel the evil and tell us now
some people for the not yet muslims they
feel that islam
is something that encourages violence
that encourages terrorism
that islam is radical what do you got to
say about this
i feel sorry for those people who were
misinformed about
islam if they really
read islam about islam they will find
that
none of these is true as a matter of
fact
the messenger of allah had neighbors who
were not muslim
messenger of allah used to accept the
invitation
of not muslim never in his life that he
said i don't want to come to you
because you're not muslim i don't want
to deal with you
because you're not muslim yet i don't
want to come to your house
because it's not for my faith as a
matter of fact he used to entertain
every invitation that was ever given to
him
from not muslim not only that he used to
take care of them if they if they sick
he will go and visit them
if they in need he will take care of
their need and so on
so these people who are writing about
islam sometimes
i ask myself what religion are they
talking about
because this is not my religion whatever
they're talking about
is not in islam so my my advice
to anyone who's watching here is listen
you're very intelligent person use your
own mind
go out there read the quran
read the teaching of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
read what islam is all about and do not
follow what these people try to say
about islam
who do not know anything about islam so
it's clear we've done shows on this in
the past but we just want people to
relax a little bit
a muslim might have got his non-muslim
friend and now they heard islam and
muslim they think whoa
whoa something's going on here there
might be something blowing up
they have bombs in the masjid your
mosque
that you're the imam do you invite do
you encourage people to come
and to visit you there no matter what
faith to come in dialogue to talk with
you to see what's going on
absolutely i invite everyone i
invite them to my mosque i invite them
to this conference i invite them
to my house my neighbors and say listen
what do you think about me
what do you think about us you want to
see how we pray do you even want to see
what we do in the mosque
this is all yours it's open doors and
it's open policy
if you see something please you know
then tell us
so every time they come and visit us
they say well you know i'm
shocked this is not the islam that i
heard about this is not what these
groups said about
uh this is not islam they're talking
about this is completely different thing
so most of the time they go out and they
accept islam
or they go out of the masjid with a
positive
image so i'm asking the muslim take that
opportunity go to your mosque
go to islamic events go to your muslims
and you know
examine the situation you ask the
question you
talk to them and then you will see a
completely different
image of islam in the last few moments
that we have
back to the youth now what closing
comments and advice do you have for
those youth that are struggling
with all the different trials that are
out there but they want to not succumb
to that they want to come to the right
way
but they just need a little extra push
there's only one way
only one way and that is allah subhana
wa
nothing will save you with this
miserable life that you're living
nothing will save you with this you know
difficult thing time that you're going
through
no one can save you but allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala so
return and turn to allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and don't worry about
anything else and allah is there for you
thank you may god almighty the creator
of the heavens and earth allah rewards
you again for being with us
and thank you for tuning in again to
another episode of the dean show where
we're trying to
invite to everything that's good and you
got the advice
from the imam from the sheikh that turn
to who
turn to the one creator the same god
that jesus peace be upon him turned to
the same god that moses
abraham and the last and final messenger
sent to mankind
turned to beseech his help he created
this whole universe and everything in it
and what can he do if he did all that
definitely he can help you it's that
simple it's that easy but you gotta want
it
you gotta want to change you gotta want
his help
beseech him he will definitely help you
and come back here every week to the
dean show
we'll see you next time until then peace
be unto you
the assalamu to him belong the heavens
and
the earth
sent his messengers
to all his creatures
of the grave danger
of worship in other
than allah there is
none greater than
the creator
there is none greater
than the creator of